hello and welcome to our webinar on
blended learning for digital marketers
hi I'm Dan B burner I'm your host and
the blended learning specialist I'm here
with Josh Pfister he's the director of
enterprise sales that simply learn hello
Josh thank you for joining us good
morning Dan thank you very much I'm
excited to be here I would like to
welcome everyone to the blended learning
for digital marketing webinar really
excited to be here today I've had a
number of conversations with business
leaders and really understand how
important learning and development and
and having sharp skills are for all of
the organizations so we have a
presentation put together for you here
today that is going to cover the
following topics so I'm just going to
hop right over to our agenda here we're
going to start off with a brief overview
of the simply learn so I'm going to give
you a just a slight little bit of
company history then we'll move into
challenges facing the industry agency
then we'll move over to the
effectiveness of a blended learning
approach to professional education and
then we will wrap up with a Q&A session
so with that being said a little bit
about simply learned so quick background
on the company we were founded in 2009
starting with a focus on project
management and then moved into IT
service architecture in 2015 simply
learn acquired market motives a Silicon
Valley based digital marketing education
firm that founded the online marketing
and certified professionals industry
certification body now we continue to
work with OMC P to this day because the
board members and industry experts of
that organization are defining the key
capabilities of digital marketers as
such this is how we align and validate
our digital marketing curriculum at the
end of the day we have the experience of
training over 1 million learners at over
2,000 companies in more than 150
countries around the world which has
really validated the academic structure
and impact of our programs on
individuals and organizations so with
that being said before we really get
into the meat and potatoes so to save
the of the webinar today I'd like to
start with a survey and I'm
curious to know what digital solutions
have you found to have the greatest
demand by your agency clients will leave
the poll open for about 10 or 15 seconds
and give everyone an opportunity to
respond we'll close the poll and then
we'll see what kind of results we get
all right looks like the poll is closed
and let's see what kind of results we
have here thank you very much Dan for
sharing that I really appreciate it so
the reason we asked about demand is
because of the major shifts we've seen
that our impact in the agency industry
so that takes us to the challenges that
are facing the agency industry today now
from an ad week article published March
1st they point out that 2018 is shaping
up to be a year when some of the largest
CPG brands are making some very bold
moves both Procter & Gamble and Li
Unilever two of the biggest CPG brands
in the world are demanding more out of
their digital advertising by putting
pressure on platforms and making
agencies air quotes clean up their act
now what we are saying is that
traditionally large marketing agency
agency spenders are spending a lot of
money to bring training up on digital
marketing topics in the house and in
many instances cutting agencies spend
nearly in half so that's challenge
number one
challenge number two that we've
identified through our work with
hundreds of agencies and private sector
organizations that there is a
significant skills gap in knowing what
digital marketing is and then actually
applying digital marketing concepts to
campaign strategies as one business
leader that I was speaking with put it
our sales staff understands what digital
marketing is but they are having a hard
time putting together a mixed discipline
solution that will meet the objectives
of a clients what we need is an
education program that helps them to
connect the dots if you mix blue and
yellow you get green if you mix social
media with content and PPC you get X
result as
so understanding how all of the digital
marketing disciplines work together to
form a total solution is severely
lacking so that's challenge number two
what that all means is that there is a
seismic shift happening right now that
has proven some very significant skills
gaps are currently rearing their ugly
heads if you will one might think that
these gaps can be filled by hiring well
but as you will see in the upcoming
slide the demand for these skills far
exceeds the supply of qualified
candidates available in the marketplace
here's just a quick little graph that
kind of illustrates this a little bit
the demand for digital marketing talent
as you see Digital Marketing at 56% is
far above any other marketing function
or operation listed here and this is a
through a survey last year from McKinley
now you see creative services being a
35% marketing operations at 27% research
and analysis of 25% product marketing at
20 and then traditional marketing at 19
so I think it's quite obvious that
digital marketing is really capturing
the majority of attention today
now as the old adage goes the proof is
in the pudding well in this case the
proof is in the publications here are
some interesting statistics behind the
demand for digital marketing by
conductor comm we see that the trend
continues to point towards less siloing
and a more holistic approach to
marketing increasingly dependent on that
versified skills and that speaks to one
of the challenges that I mentioned just
in the previous slides
according to burning glass research in
their August 2017 study 40% of marketing
jobs now call for digital marketing
skills the demand for digital marketing
professionals will rise by 38% just this
year according to mondo comm and then
based upon a u.s. digital marketing
forecast survey from 2014 to 2019 if
the digital marketing will top a hundred
billion dollars in account for 35% of
all marketing spending by 2019 but as
you can see here the talent to fill
those demands is very scarce the u.s. by
itself needs 230,000 more people with
marketing skills and that's according to
a May 2018 linked in the workforce
report some very recent information the
fact that that that number is so large
is really quite staggering 85% of
agencies claim that they found it either
very or somewhat difficult to hire
quality employees and that's according
to another publication industry
publication adweek comm and that was
from earlier this year now here's some
very interesting numbers and we're
seeing huge increases in these spaces
demand for content marketing has risen
450 percent in the last five years no
wonder that they say content is king
right now digital analytics demand also
grew 152 percent and marketers will
increase analytic spending by three
hundred and seventy five percent in the
next two to four years and that comes
from the CMO survey by Deloitte now
finally from upwork.com in 2017 they
found that marketers are difficult to
hire 35% of hiring managers felt hiring
got harder in the past year being 2017
so again speaking to the challenge that
the industry agency industry is facing
there's these skill gaps but the talent
just is not in the the workforce or out
in the public to be hired to bring in so
that takes us to our next survey
question and that is what digital
disciplines you find suffer from the
greatest lack of fluency
that's your agency today and I'll pause
for just a moment and give everyone a
chance to respond we'll leave it open
for about 10-15 seconds and then we'll
see what kind of results we have
all right thank you very much dancing
around one for your participation there
so we're going to go ahead and move
forward here a little bit and at this
point I'm actually going to pass it back
over to Dan who is our in-house expert
on blended learning and he's going to
talk to you a little bit about what
blended learning is and why it's so
important so that being said Dan may go
ahead pass the mic over to you great
thank you very much Josh
so the first thing I want to talk about
is what is blended learning well at its
most basic blended learning complements
live instructor-led classroom training
with online content usually in the form
of on-demand videos that learners review
outside of class blended learning
represents a fundamental shift in
instruction that has a potential to
optimize for the individual student in
ways that traditional instruction never
could simply learns blended learning
process combines the convenience of
self-paced online training the personal
attention of instructor led live virtual
classroom instruction and we had the
hands-on practice made possible through
projects and online labs that blended
delivery modes allow for each aspect to
be taught using the most appropriate
medium for the topic at that particular
stage in the training now every L&D
professional probably every parent of
school-aged child has heard that
different people learn differently so in
1992 researchers develop popular model
for learning called the Vark and the the
var came modalities theory stands for
visual when people learn best through
sight oral or auditory when people will
learn by hearing or speaking read
written when people learn when things
are displayed as words and kinesthetic
when people learn by physical use or
practice other researchers have broken
these modalities into even more distinct
learning styles including a there's
logical social when people learn through
interaction with other people and
solitary when people learn best alone
through self-study with so many
different learning styles to address
that a blended learning system already
makes sense
for people who learn visually or through
reading and ideally alone of course
online self-paced video deliveries is
the best mode social and our learners
gain most from live instructor led
classrooms meanwhile the hands-on
practice from engaging an implied
learning project satisfies those with a
kinesthetic or logical learner style
there's another theory that goes on with
learning and this is the 70-20-10 model
now according to these findings 7% of
benificial learning comes from hands-on
experience in projects 20% comes from
learning from others through social
experiences like coaching mentoring and
collaborative assignments and then
finally 10% of effective learning comes
from traditional course based
instruction the addition of
computer-based multimedia has been said
to help people learn more information
and less time than traditional classroom
lectures this was discovered by research
at the Georgia Institute of Technology
and they found that that information
when is presented to a redundant
instructor and multimedia content
process appears to be the most effective
way to enforce learning now of course
all these percentages are awfully round
and they're often debated more recently
L&T experts say that the computer age
has has changed the ratios to be more
like 50 30 20 well regardless of the
numbers blended learning provides
multiple modes of instruction that
simultaneously support all of these
models so Josh let's look at the
different types of learners that we have
in our organization another important
factor to consider when it comes to
delivering blended learning training
programs to your agency is the preferred
learning style of people in your
different generations of all the people
that are working together in the same
office so as you see here we have the
Silent Generation those are born between
the 1920s to the early 1940s and they
prefer instructor directed lectures
structure and predictability with no
surprises is very important to these
types of learners and they also like
independent skilled practice time now as
more experienced members of the team
members of this generation can also be
ideal
mentors and select roles and
organizations then we have baby boomers
baby boomers expect a more personally
focused learning structure the classroom
continues to be an effective setting
although members of this generation tend
to learn best through in class
participation and inclusive
decision-making group interactions
discussions and feedback and that kind
of brings them more directly into the
process and also like the Silent
Generation they tend to like to try new
skills independently then we start to
see a bit of a shift when we get to
Generation X Generation X are often
noted as the most fiercely independent
of the four groups they prioritize
self-directed educational opportunities
and programs that enable them to learn
with their own schedule
they prefer fun activities relevance and
understanding of what's in it for me and
they also like the discretion to
complete tasks in their own way
at their own pace finally there are the
Millennials now they combine the
learning preferences of the two
predecessor groups favoring both highly
personalized training on a self-directed
schedule and also lots of activity based
group work they also enjoy
individualized feedback and mentoring
and technology enabled learning now
that's what's important because this
includes their own devices during class
Millennials are now the largest
individual group of learners in the
workplace today a very important note
here is their emphasis on technology
enable learning everything from mobile
devices to their computers at home to
their laptops and their phones this is
important because your course delivery
must apply to every single one of them
from hands-on labs to exercises and
that's another advantage of blended
learning then what we can do on the
online delivery aspect of it okay let's
take a look at blended learning as a
whole so even if these learning theories
fall into doubt as to which one is
better blended learning still makes a
good sense especially from a digital
marketing perspective first the time and
costs involved in conducting surveys to
determine the preferred medium whether
is videos books
or remote instruction adds another
burden to agencies trying to achieve
outcomes under budget
now especially when it comes to
technology skills there are many
elements that can only be taught
effectively through one particular mode
for example some digital marketing
concepts like email display advertising
and that sort of thing are best shared
two words graphs and visual examples
gaining practical skills and something
like analytics or even PPC requires more
hands-on practical experience those of
us that use AdWords know that it's not
something to necessarily be taught from
reading materials you really have to
practice it out and having an online lab
situation where you're able to simulate
these with a budget that you don't have
to provide yourself can really give you
the dynamic element to experiment and
learn from your pay-per-click and other
activities numerous studies show how
learning is improved for most everyone
by combining different activities
alongside more passive study by
utilizing as many learning delivery
modes as possible that includes video
live instructor social and practical you
can fill in any knowledge gaps left by
modes that were less than optimal for
the specific topic or that particular
learner now the best solution lies in
blending those delivery modes so that
each aspect is taught using the most
appropriate medium for the topic at that
particular stage in the training and
benefiting the largest number of people
possible I mean it's just like digital
marketing itself you know the right
message the right person at the right
time and this is the right learning
through the right process to the right
learner at their particular pace and
time what's important to remember too is
that the research also shows that
redundancy through multiple delivery
modes improves learning and especially
retention so with that I'm going to pass
the mic back over to Josh and he's going
to share some information with you about
simply learns approach about blended
learning all right hey thanks a lot Dan
that was a lot of really good
information really the science of
blended learning so thank you very much
for taking your time to present all that
nation thanks Josh certainly so alright
so we're going to take a look at what
blended learning looks like at simply
learning how we deliver our programs so
in short it includes self-directed
online learning instructor led live
virtual classrooms and now those are
available in three different ways one
the first is a public schedule of
instructor-led virtual classrooms and we
also do private deliveries so it's just
groups of people from your agency with
an instructor and those are usually
tailored sessions but those can be
delivered also in a virtual classroom
and we can we can do them on-site at
your facilities as well if that's the
preferred delivery modality now all of
this is also supported with applied
learning through labs graded projects in
course assessment so really the
engagement component right and then of
course we always have the 24 by 7
available teaching assistants and
technical support for students as well
now some very important aspects that I
want to put on here is the use of
pre-assessments the on-the-go learning
capabilities through a mobile
application and the engagement model for
hands-on learning so starting with pre
assessments there's two use cases for
leveraging pre-assessments now the first
which is the preferred model is to use
the pre assessment as a tool to
benchmark right so you give everyone
within that you plan to train your
entire audience you put all of them
through the same pre assessment and then
your outcomes there are your benchmark
of current skills knowledge and
capabilities if you put everyone through
the exact same learning plan and then
test again at the end to see how much
the benchmark moved now the second use
case it's to use the pre assessment as a
prescriptive tool and while that
approach will save the organization and
the learners some time because they
probably won't be going through as broad
of a learning set there are a couple of
caveats that take into consideration
here
the first is people do get lucky on
tests right so hypothetically you've got
a student that doesn't necessarily know
SEO but they get lucky and the guests
write on a couple of questions and by
guessing right it puts them just above
the level that they need to be to pass
now the unfortunate situation here is
that you end up with a false positive
and a person that really needs training
on SEO isn't going to get it because
you're going to build a custom learning
plan based upon their pre assessment
results
that's caveat number one now copy out
number two and I think that this is
maybe a little bit more relevant than
getting lucky on a test second caveat is
that digital marketing is a very rapidly
changing and evolving space something
new is always coming up and a person may
sit down to take this pre assessment and
they may be knowledgeable in say again
SEO but their knowledge may be based
upon experiences two to three years old
now they're proficient enough to pass a
test however they don't necessarily know
SEO as it is today do they new do they
know that the new Google algorithms for
example right so while that person may
be proficient and have a bit of
experience determining whether or not
they should be taking training may not
necessarily be appropriate to base that
decision off of a off of a pre
assessment right because you really want
to level set knowledge across the
organization and make sure everyone is
up to speed with the latest and greatest
now the second component that I want to
point out here is the mobile on-the-go
learning and as van pointed out the
Millennial workforce is the largest
individual group of people in the
workplace today right so simply learn
has created an application and through
the application on a mobile device
students can attend publicly scheduled
live virtual classrooms via their mobile
device they can also download the
content of their of their learning
programs their elearning programs onto
their mobile so if they're in a
situation where they're offline they on
a flight for example they can still
consume their e-learning in an
line mode now when they go back online
the application syncs up with the LMS in
the backend and the next time that
student logs into their their learning
program whether it's from home or from
the office on their PC they can pick up
right where they left off this really
fosters a learn anywhere at anytime type
of an environment for students that
really are stretched thin for time and
it provides them with an opportunity to
consume their programs when they've got
the capability to do so now the third
component here that I really want to
highlight is the engagement model right
now the way that we provide engagement
to learners particularly in digital
marketing is through assignments air
quotes hands-on labs because we do
actually have a digital marketing lab
environment and project work now the the
lab component is a platform called mimic
pro and what mimic Pro does is it
provides learners an opportunity to
build and run a campaign from building
the landing page on through to buying
Adwords and you name it right they get a
$50,000 funny-money budget to build this
campaign and the really neat thing about
this platform is that it's feeding in
live data from Google so they're buying
Adwords
at today's prices now once their project
is complete and they've built and run
this campaign they actually get to see
how that campaign would perform in a
real world environment now all of that
is supported by our global teaching
assistants and we also have project
mentoring sessions available so as
students are working on those projects
they're not left alone to do it part of
our publicly scheduled delivery for our
digital marketing certified associate
course as an example also has project
mentoring sessions scheduled into the
structure of the delivery and those are
like open office hours where students
can log in they can ask questions about
their projects and they can get
assistance or ask questions and you can
get guidance if they're having trouble
understanding a particular topic
so that takes us to our next survey and
I'm curious to know from your
perspective what modes of learning have
been the most effective at your agency
is it self-directed eLearning is it open
enrollment instructor-led training
that's on a public schedule maybe it's
private instructor led training or
perhaps a blend of both
of course hands-on practical training
would hopefully be a component of every
delivery model or you don't know
interested to see your answers here now
we'll leave the poll open for a few
seconds so go ahead and make your
selection and we'll close it out here in
just a moment and see what the results
look like
I'd like to start off by giving a better
understanding of what the digital
marketing education programs that are
out there available for you through
simply learn now starting with
foundational level learning we have
programs that are designed to take new -
career team members or those who have
little to no digital marketing fluency
to a level of understanding that makes
them very conversant and capable of
sitting down in the computer and
starting to build and run campaigns how
we then move to advanced level learning
and that helps on those who have at
least one to two years of experience in
digital marketing and they're looking to
become experts in their functional areas
now these courses dive deep into the
technical workings of the discipline
also included in this catalog our
shorter courses that are very platform
specific so topics such as YouTube
Facebook Pinterest Twitter Google
AdWords and then because we have
master's programs as well that cover
multiple topic areas across both
foundational and advanced level
curriculum now you'll notice the Oh mCP
tag in the upper right and as a reminder
that is a group of thought leaders and
experts out of the Silicon Valley that
have really identified what it means to
be a digital marketing expert right and
we've aligned those are our courses to
their certifications they have two
levels of certification there's om CA
which is online marketing certified
associate and our digital marketing
certified associate course which is
identified in the upper left hand of the
foundational level track align us of the
OM CA now what that course does is it
brings together all of the essential
level disciplines into one course in the
form of eLearning
we also have publicly scheduled live
instructor led training programs for
that and then of course it includes all
the opportunities for hands-on learning
and running the lab so to say with nimac
pro now om c pees other certification is
its namesake the the advanced
certification is om CP and our set of
balanced courses are aligned to the Oh
mCP certification now the reason that I
share that information is because I
think it's important for everyone here
to understand that these courses aren't
simply learn telling you what you need
to know about digital marketing
it's the who's who of digital marketing
that are out the industry that have said
this is what's really important for a
digital marker marketer to know and
understand how to do and as we've
aligned our courses to that so our
courses have been vetted and approved by
ONC P as we are a registered education
provider now I did mention the the
master's programs and also earlier
mention that it's not enough for a
marketer just to note SEO or just no
social media right all of the digital
marketing disciplines are really
intervene and connected to truly be
effective functional team members have
to understand how these different
disciplines affect one another and
ultimately how they combine to impact
strategy so with this in mind we have
created our masters programs with the
help of industry experts to define the
role specific learning paths as you see
here a social media marketer needs to
know more than just social media they
also have to understand the importance
of content marketing and web analytics
and how that impacts social the same
goes for SEO and PPC PPC specialists as
well now common question that our
clients ask is how are these courses
developed delivered and supported and I
believe that on this page is a great
snapshot that answers all three points
so first we work with a network of
world-class influencers and industry
experts like brad geddes and Stefan
Stefan Hamel and those are the
individuals who helped us to develop our
courses within source instructors who
are both teachers and practitioners who
bring real-world examples and hands-on
application in the classroom guys like
Jeff Ferguson and Matt Bailey um these
guys are out there on a day to day basis
doing digital marketing as their
full-time jobs well they also happen to
have taught a number of people how to do
this
well so those are the types of extras
that we bring in to help teach our
classes because they can really take the
level of learner they can take a
learning from theory-based to more of an
application based right and of course
all learning is in further supported by
industry segmented global teaching
assistance to help us find or how I'm
sorry helps students rather find answers
to questions or provide direction on in
course projects this provides us with a
in the end system of expert development
delivery and support now when it comes
to the delivery of digital learning
there are also key capabilities that are
necessary within the delivery platform
that provides you know so we can provide
students with an easy to navigate learn
anywhere anytime ecosystem additionally
it's important to address the needs of
the learning and development
organization and the goals and metrics
they track in order to achieve a return
on the investment of their education
dollars spent now we help drive this by
providing an enterprise-grade LMS that
allows client managers to group learners
together into teams set custom learning
pads and then pull reporting and
analytics to see things such as who's
registered for what classes what
percentage of the course of they
completed how are they scoring on in
course assessments projects in the final
exam now having this information not
only helps you understand the health of
your program
there also provides you with a mechanism
to drive learner accountability for
those who are not holding up their end
of the bargain unfortunately and these
organizations will invest quite a bit of
money in learning and development and
providing resources and they make it
available to the to this to their staff
and there are some folks that are really
engaged to jump right in and they really
go for it
but unfortunately there are others that
kind of lag behind the ability to pull
reports to see the level of engagement
gives you another way to go to those
learners that might be following up
falling behind to see if there's
something you can do to help them to get
them re-engaged in learning and getting
them to complete their programs
all right we're on to our next survey
here so I'm I'm curious to know how
you're currently measuring engagement in
your learning programs today I've come
across some organizations that
unfortunately are still tracking their
learning programs by using excel sheets
which is a very manual way of doing it
manage your debriefing or informal
feedback one-on-one with with their
learners others do manual investigation
through their e-learning management
systems and in pull reports in there and
others have a bit of a more
sophisticated way of doing it through
automated reporting through a learning
management system and then in some cases
we've found that folks are not measuring
it at all so interested to see your
feedback here now finally I'd like to
talk about customer success so at the
start of every relationship all of our
clients are assigned dedicated customer
success manager now the customer success
manager gets involved right from the
beginning to work with you on defining
the detailed solution right they help
you identify the goals and success
metrics that you're chasing within the
engagement they also work to help you
with the logistical pieces behind the
delivery whether that's loading learners
into the LMS or coordinating with the
instructor for a private group delivery
now they also take the time to Train
managers and the students on our LMS its
features functions reporting and how to
use it and once once the program is
launched there's ongoing reporting
provided back against the benchmarks
identified at the onset so we don't put
the onus back on the clients to pull the
reporting we do that on a Mac on a
monthly basis and then of course can
generate reports on demand as needed and
with that ladies and gentlemen that
brings us to the end of our webinar
today this is my pleasure and thank you
all very much for being here I sincerely
appreciate it
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here